when you booked your job on Star Wars at
that time how big a deal was it was it
similar to today booking a job on
Avengers or because it was a smaller
movie I think what he was sharing the
casting space with Brian DePalma and
they were making Carrie they were kind
of swapping actors I don't know do you
want this person I'll take him yeah okay
I like that Mark Hamill guys supposedly
on the Carrie behind the scenes they
said that yeah but how I'm sorry so it's
how was that to to work was it was it
not a huge deal at that moment because
we didn't know the effect of it or well
I had originally interviewed with George
Lucas and Gary Kurtz to to do the visual
effects to be the to be the first unit
visual effects director and I you know I
had I spent a lot of time in my early
career saying oh I've done that I don't
want to do that anymore I can I'm going
in this new direction so so I had been
shooting as a live-action DP a bunch of
pictures for Roger Corman and so that
was the direction that my career was
going so my good friend John Dykstra got
the the job to do the main unit and
visual effects and they invented this
incredible motion control system which
enabled you to shoot models moving very
fast you know in 2001 the spaceships
were moving so slowly that you could
just shoot them single frame and it was
fine but you know when you have a ship
that's moving really fast once a game
you know the motion blur became really
important so that meant that you have to
shoot the model while the camera and the
model were in
so during the exposure which might be as
long as four seconds or something you
know that the model was actually in
motion and the camera was in motion at
the same time and that took the
invention of motion control software and
it had never been used at this scale for
so many shots before so so when George
got back from shooting the live action
in England he he he walked into
Industrial Light & Magic and said well
where's the footage you know and they
really hadn't shot any footage because
they'd been developing this hardware
software system and so he got like we he
got really frustrated and he he he
called me up to work on this little
second unit and he had this harebrained
scheme where he wanted some puppeteers
in black velvet suits and he wanted to
put the models on long black rods and
like flying a puppeteer them in front of
the lens so that they were you know that
the puppeteers were flying the so and so
it was kind of like a live-action way of
getting some of that model photography
well of course that didn't work out at
all it was a really bad idea but my unit
then turned into this pyrotechnic unit
and there was this kid Joe is coastal
who was who made really made these
really great little miniature bombs and
there you know he was so we so we
started shooting these explosions and we
would shoot I would look directly up at
his explosions so they would explode it
over the lens and therefore give it the
zero-g impression that it was happening
in outer space because obviously if you
if you should make an explosion normally
you get a big mushroom cloud and it
doesn't doesn't look like it's in outer
space
we started off letting these little
bombs off and it was quite successful
and shooting them with the high-speed
cameras and then we got bigger and
bigger and we moved on to much bigger
stages until eventually we we had like a
40-foot blue screen and we would drop
the wire down in the middle of that blue
screen and we would light the blue
screen with like I think the way eight
arc lamps you know which were the most
powerful lamps that you could get in
those days and shooting them with a
VistaVision camera and we would we would
shoot up through a piece of glass which
was were two sawhorses and a piece of
plywood and a hole cut out to shoot
through and then a piece of glass was
over that to protect the lens and then
we we let off these bigger and bigger
bombs until finally we had the
explosions that we needed for blowing up
the the Death Star and also for blowing
up old Iran and I also shot a whole
bunch of my friends at Industrial Light
and Magic were making all these
beautiful models and I got the blow mop
so it was a fun little shoot then the
reception of the movie were you
anticipating the reception or were you
surprised I was very surprised by the
reception of the movie you know I think
we went to see it at the Academy theater
and we say hey this is this is really
nice but then like within a day or so
there were these long lines outside the
movie and you know it it's kind of a
trick that theater owners do they like
to keep their audience wait waiting on
the street so it looks like a hit movie
in that so everybody drives by and C
sees a line of people but these were
like these were going around the block
you know so yeah it was unlike 2001
which had this really kind of slow bill
Star Wars was like a instant hit
and that summer but then who knew it
would grow into such a franchise and you
know it just went from strength to
strength until it's I guess the world's
biggest franchise right now him anything
you observe with working with George
Lucas in terms of how he worked how he
worked with actors his work ethic that
you felt you wanted to emulate as well
George was very very good to work with
he really knew what he wanted and and
where he was going with it and he knew
what you he wanted you to do so I really
enjoyed the fact that he was so prepared
he also had he had a technique which we
now called a Ripper Matic and that
technique was - he got footage from old
world war ii movies like the dam Busters
and tora tora tora and he basically cut
his end action sequence out of footage
from these World War 2 movies and then
that became a template for the effects
because you know you you'd go to the cut
and you'd say okay I need a ship moving
from left to right and another one
coming in this way and it's going to be
17 frames long so it was a way of you
know they have whole departments in
movies now called previous for doing
this kind of work now but back then this
was a technique I'd never seen before
and it worked really really well
you